SPEAKER: The storage permission
is a fairly far-reaching
permission, giving
read or write access
to basically your device's
entire internal storage.
Instead of requesting
the world, consider
using Scoped Directory
Access to request access
to just what you
need, whether it's
on internal storage, SD cards,
or USB-attached storage.
Scoped Directory
Access relies heavily
on a new class called
storage volume.
There's always a
primary storage value
that corresponds
with the environment
to get external
storage directory.
Then there can be any
number of secondary storage
volumes for SD cards and
USB devices, for instance.
To retrieve a storage volume,
you'll use Storage Manager.
You can either get just
the primary storage volume
or get a list of all
available storage volumes.
Now, this is where Scope
Directory Access comes in.
You can use the storage
volumes to create access intent
method with
startActivityForResult
to request access to a specific
folder on that storage volume.
For secondary
storage volumes, you
can also request access
to the entire volume
by passing in null.
So if you want access to the
standard pictures directory,
for instance, you'd pass in
Environment DIRECTORY_PICTURES.
Assuming the user
accepts, you'll
get a call back to
onActivityResult
with a document tree URI for
the directory you requested
with read and write
access to the directory
through the documents contracts
methods or the helper documents
file class.
Now, unless this is
a one time operation,
strongly consider calling
takePersistableUriPermission
with the URI you receive.
This will ensure that you won't
have to ask over and over again
for the same directory.
In addition, many of the
action media broadcasts
sent by the system have
been updated to include
extra storage volume
to tell you exactly
which storage volume was
just mounted or unmounted.
Super useful for
updating your UI
or kicking off the Scope
Directory Access flow.
The important part to
keep in mind with this
is that your app gets to
pick what directories it
needs access to.
If you want the user to be
able to select any arbitrary
directory, you'd
instead want to use
the ACTION_OPEN_DOCUMENT_TREE
intent.
So don't scare users
away by requesting access
to their entire device.
Access only what you need
with Scope Directory Access.
But most importantly, just
continue to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]